il legame del belize rytas oasi
nuovissimo episodio in cui proverò i
trucchetti per nascondere gli snack al
cinema western il quarto episodio gli
scorsi episodi mi sono piaciuti
tantissimo quindi se anche questo
episodio raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace ci
sarà anche un quinto episodio qui spolli
chat e subito qua sotto potete vedere un
berlino che oggi parteciperà anche lui
ad aiutarmi a non spendere gli snack al
cinema dal controllore in pochi se avete
visto l'episodio precedente e berlina
stato bravissimo alla fine del video
scriveteli commenti quale il trucchetto
che vi è piaciuto più di tutti e qual è
il momento che vi ha fatto più ridere e
non mi seguite su instagram andate
seguirmi lo evita stories se volete
seguitemi anche su tutto mettetevi
comodi prendete i pop corn e iniziamo
con il primo trucchetto per il primo
trucchetto utilizzerò un cerchietto
questo è il mio cerchietto grifondoro
andrò ad attaccare degli snack qua
attorno al cerchio e sperando che il
controllore pensi che sono solo
decorazioni del cerchietto è il nome mac
che sto cercando di intrufolare di lo
scotto
iniziamo ad attaccarli speriamo che non
cadano
ecco qua il mio cerchietto pieno di
snack hanno anche rumore è meglio se non
muovo la testa troppo altrimenti
potrebbero cadere
secondo voi se ne accorgerà il controllo
speriamo di no andiamo subito
[Musica]
prego per posso andare sì sì certo può
andare via
cos'è quell'uomo scanner è uno scanner
se non ho mentito nascondersi non si
deve preoccupare non hanno capito siamo
in giro ma nono di un aeroporto non si
può portare il cibo e questo è uno
scanner speciale apposta fatto da di
cibo sembra ci sia qualcosa qua sopra
cosa tra i capelli per caso la cina ma
forse il soffitto faccio vedere che
cos'è questo tua ma è bellissimo c'è la
strada giusta può sembrare anche se
provo una volta rimosse tutte le cose
sospette che non c'è più alcun problema
e si può entrare
questo invece lo tengo io qua ma vi sta
proprio bene
orsi che sono un controllore alla moda o
no merlino abbiamo fallito il primo
round ci ha sequestrato il cerchietto
troppo il controllore a una nuova il
body scanner o snack scampini dovremo
stare molto più attenti con i trucchetti
d'ora in poi considerando che lui farà
sempre il controllo con lo scanner siamo
al prossimo trucchetto e cerchiamo di
non farsi scoprire via prossimo
trucchetto per il prossimo trucchetto mi
avete consigliato voi di mettermi una
felpa abbastanza larga con una tasca e
mettere gli snack nella tasca e dentro
alla felpa
speriamo che funzioni io ero metterò più
snake possibili dentro la tav che
vediamo quanti ce ne sta bene iniziamo
mette un bel po di snack speriamo che ce
ne siano tanti se celestini
altri circoletti vediamo se si sta un
pacco di patatine
gli devo dire che in piazza tosta ci
sono tante cose ok direi di fermarci qua
altrimenti potrebbe accorgersene perché
è un po gonfia questa tasca ma io mi
metterò così farò finta di niente
ce la faremo questa volta abbiamo
tensione obbligatoria non sono permessi
ex altri snack dolci salati agrodolci
agro salati e dolci e salati salati o
dolci sacro sodo ci sarà insomma
qualsiasi cosa non è permessa la coda è
sì è proprio qui nelle tasche suoni
tutte le tasche
sì direi che è proprio questo vieni ecco
tutti i big mac questi sono tutti i miei
tre corde per svuotare tutte le tasche
e va bene ha consegnato tutto questa
volta potrebbe andare ha detto no prima
l'ultimo screzio nè ok prego può andare
adesso
questa sera rotanti smetto per me no
grazie al suo body scanner o anzi snack
scanner è riuscito a scoprire che
nascondeva nella tasca della felpa
quindi purtroppo non ha funzionato e
roma in mente un altro trucchetto che
secondo me potrebbe funzionare anche se
lui usa il body scanner snack scanner
prossimo trucchetto speriamo di farcela
per questo trucchetto ho in mente un
piano forse geniale vi ricordate quando
ho messo una cloche qua nella pancia e
ho fatto finta di essere gente allo
riempita di snack questa volta farò la
stessa cosa però la metterò qua nella
schiena se fosse una gobba anche questo
trucchetto me lo avete consigliato voi
voi siete veramente super super
furbissimi e intelligenti nate pure a
consigliarmi i vostri trucchetti nei
conventi perché sono troppo divertente
pensando perché non rimetti direttamente
nel cappuccio perché ho già provato una
volta ma non ha funzionato per lo
ricordate cross già riempita di snack e
ora provo a metterli nella schiena
spero che non cadrà niente che non se ne
accorgerà con il suo body scanner
sembra che la farcia al contrario
guardate se anche questo coso pa che per
afferrare la cloche che sembrati poco
proprio un bel in un gruppo di carte se
tutti voi ci cascherà andiamo ai
proviamo
pronto sì chi no ha sbagliato numero
prima che mal di schiena o biglietto non
ho messo il biglietto si sbrighi un
fortissimo mal di schiena dove entrare
subito ma come è successo lo schema il
colpo della befana nome della strega
colpo della storia detto che non prego
faccia non solo una piccola stazione per
vedere che tutto ok ti direi che tutto
ok
saremo davvero si certo
ok ma che cela dietro e la mia schiena
che lo ha detto questa è una bomba più
che un mal di statisti e un mal di
schiena talmente forte che che il ceto
medio che sono molto doloroso prego
prego si accomodi grazie prego mi
raccomando stia al caldo incredibile
spero non mi verrà mai il colpo della
strega
siamo riusciti a passare come back
nascosti dentro alla gobba finta non ha
passato il body scanner snack scanner
nella gobba e cornate color quanti snack
che vi faccio vedere subito il profumo
trucchetto ultimo trucchetto per questo
ultimo trucchetto mi aiuterà la mascotte
della soris family il nostro fedele
aiutante berlino
grazie per questi motivi mi berlin
berlino è molto felice e ci aiuterà a
berlino praticamente android incollare
gli snack nel guinzaglio poi attaccherò
il guinzaglio berlino e farò finta che
sto portando berlino fare una
passeggiata al cinema si lo so è strana
però l'altra volta ci ha fatto entrare
con berlino quindi speriamo che funzioni
anche questo speriamo che con il body
scanner non si accorga che ci sono gli
snack cola ma non dovrebbe ispezionare
anche il guinzaglio con il body scanner
e speriamo che non ispezioni merlino
prepariamo ora il guinzaglio e
attacchiamo gli snack
speriamo che non cada ecco qua il
guinzaglio con degli snack 6 pranzo
berlina e kevin taglio degli snack per
l'idv ed allora andiamo
andiamo lì è così chiaro che certo
eccolo il cambio villaggio globale
perché lo devo ripetere è la star
guardi tutte queste locandine berlino
stories scusata prego di scusarmi il
signor bambino stories lo faccio subito
entrare devo solo fare un piccolo
controllo credo lo scanner tanti snack
crediamo che gli diamo quindi ma suonato
posso nascondere qui niente le nasconde
qualcosa signora star
no non nasconde proprio un bel niente
aiuta anche facendo accomodare dio mi ha
legato andiamo perché io che ho legato
di meno frequentate fatto la nostra moto
niente
bravissimo grazie a vermiglio temo
riuscite intrufolare gli snack attaccati
al guinzaglio
peggio ha fatto vincere questo noi
quando abbiamo l'aiuto di berlino è
sempre più facile vero berlino
scriveteci nei commenti qual è stato il
vostro trucchetto preferito ecco
l'estate il momento più divertente
secondo voi se non avete visto discorsi
episodi dei trucchetti per nascondere il
cibo al cinema andati a vederli
cliccando su questa base lina sempre se
volete vedere altri challenge di questa
video divertenti su questa oppure questa
cliccate sulla casellina che preferite e
buona visione da me
berlino e ciao